Pour ne louper aucune vidéo, abonnez-vous
et activez la petite cloche.
Chers Epicurieux, ces derniers jours vous avez posé
beaucoup de questions sur la voile et le Vendée Globe,
pour les réponses, embarquement immédiat.
Happy aimerait savoir, quelle nourriture a embarqué
Samantha pour tenir pendant les 90 jours de course.
Alors, Samantha a de quoi tenir jusqu'à la fin janvier / début
février même si on espère qu'elle arrive avant.
Principalement de la nourriture lyophilisée
et sous vide.
Des repas qui ont été calculés au plus juste car sur
un bateau, l'ennemi c'est le poids.
D'un skipper à l'autre, cette nourriture et les produits
d'hygiène représentent entre 120 et 180 kg.
Alors pour info, il faut savoir que ces menus
ont été élaborés très longtemps à l'avance
car le Vendée Globe est une épreuve physique, certes,
il ne faut pas alourdir le bateau mais il faut aussi
recharger les batteries.
Juste pour vous donner une idée,
en temps normal, un adulte qui fait peu d'exercice
comme nous en ce moment,
dépense 2700 kilocalories si c'est un homme,
un peu plus de 2000 si c'est une femme.
En fonction de l'endroit où elle va se trouver sur le globe,
de l'état de la mer, donc de son activité physique,
Samantha pourra brûler jusqu'à 5000 kilocalories
par jour.
A ce tarif-là, je ne sais pas si la dinde aux marrons
est au menu.
Une question de Vincent Lemar,
"DisJamy,  quel poids peut peser un tel bateau ?"
Eh bien, le bateau Initiatives Coeur fait partie
de la classe IMOCA.
International Monohull Open Class Association.
Un monocoque dont la longueur est limitée à 60 pieds
soit 18,28 mètres.
Pour vous donner une idée, le Black Pearl,
le célèbre navire de Jack Sparrow, est 3 fois plus grand.
Quant au poids, le bateau de Samantha pèse 7.8t
à vide, soit un peu plus que le poids d'un éléphant d'Afrique,
mais ses voiles sont beaucoup plus grandes.
Shadow Fight 22, 22 ça doit être
le code du département les Côtes-d'Armor,
aimerait savoir si le Vendée Globe passe
par le Point Nemo.
Le Point Nemo a été nommé ainsi en référence
au héros de Vingt Mille Lieues sous les mers de Jules Verne.
C'est le point en mer le plus éloigné des côtes.
Dolor Fina a déjà répondu à Shadow Fight sur YouTube.
Pour ceux qui n'auraient pas vu sa réponse, je vous la dis.
Le Point Nemo se trouve dans l'Océan Pacifique.
Etant donné que le Vendée Globe se déroule
dans l'Océan Atlantique et l'Océan Austral,
eh bien non, cette course ne passe pas par le Point Nemo.
Une dernière info, Nemo correspond parfaitement à ce point.
En latin, ce terme signifie "personne"
et dans les 22 millions de km² qui entourent ce point,
eh bien effectivement, il n'y a personne.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo, n'hésitez pas
à laisser un pouce bleu. Merci les Epicurieux !
Pour les plus gourmands, en voici d'autres.
Et pour ne rien rater, abonnez-vous et activez la cloche !